for more on this let's bring in fox
nation host laura logan thanks for
joining us on this day after
thanksgiving i hope you had a full
holiday it's wonderful to have your
insight today uh here we are this word
that the remain in mexico policy started
under the trump administration
may be
instituted by the biden administration
your thoughts on that now
well
molly you're exactly right in saying it
remains to see be seen how this is going
to be implemented because what i'm
hearing from law enforcement sources is
that there's talk that these camps are
not going to be on the mexican side of
the border at all the biden
administration has made it very clear
from the beginning that they do not
support this policy and even after the
court ruled that it had to be
implemented they sent out internal
guidance to all of the agents to say
that they don't support it and let me
paint a picture for you of what happened
on the southern border last night this
is coming from the people the agents who
are on the ground who are actually
dealing with this right in four sectors
in texas which is the busiest there were
three border patrol agents on duty and
what the cartel did is they sent across
a couple family units right to tie up
all those border patrol agents and then
they absolutely lit the southern border
on fire with runners they were just i
mean the sensors were going berserk we
were just completely and utterly invaded
and there was absolutely nothing that
border patrol could do about it they
were calling on texas dps they were
calling on the national guard who were
trying to help but the reality is that
hundreds and hundreds of people just
flooded across the southern border last
night and the remaining mexico policy
isn't going to make any difference to
that and you know we we spent a lot of
time talking about the caravan the
caravan oh my goodness it seems to be
the only thing people care about and the
agents on the ground are saying why are
they making so much fuss about this
caravan do they not realize we get the
same number of people in that caravan we
get that sometimes in a day across the
southern border in texas alone you can
get that in two or three days or less
right and they're dealing with this
constantly and the remaining mexico
policy isn't going to solve this problem
for one very simple reason
this is still talking about the border
in terms of immigration they will not
address the cartels and everything that
is driving it the southern border that's
the cartels the people who have
operational control of our southern
border that's the cartels the people
making the money that's the cartels the
people that pose the national security
threat that is the cartels and
republicans and democrats have failed
the american people on this issue for
years laura you've hit a lot of those
highlights those points that our
correspondents down on the border have
shown some days live some of the folks
coming in behind them with border patrol
agents nowhere near some of those
runners running into the distance we've
seen that uh on our coverage throughout
the recent months if anyone's been
watching but laura i want to shift gears
a little bit because we want to
highlight something season three of your
fox nation show laura logan has no
agenda available right now on fox nation
the focus 21st century terrorism reveal
the latest episode titled global
extremism let's watch a clip
130 people were murdered hundreds more
wounded some of the terrorists had come
from the isis caliphate where the attack
was planned others were born in france
and belgium
according to umansky who works with
prosecutors when needed he showed me how
they pieced together the evidence
this has been very careful investigative
works laura tell us what's going on and
what to expect this season
well that particular episode is about
the true face of terror inside the isis
caliphate and it's fascinating because
these investigators have been on the
ground they've been talking to um
yazidis who have been freed you know
many of whom were slaves and many of the
children and they discovered something
that we've really missed in the whole
conversation about terrorism islamic
terrorism and that is that the caliphate
and isis is all about the next
generation it is about the children it
is about this messianic vision that they
have that it really doesn't matter
whether you destroy raqqa and syria you
know and and take that territory from
them you take back mosul because they
teach these children i will never see
the caliphate you may not see it but
your job is to make sure that your
children and their children that they
never stop fighting until we have taken
over the world that is what this is
really about right it's no different to
the globalists and all of these other
people they all want the same thing they
want absolute power and to have absolute
power and to hold on to it you have to
have absolute control and that's what
many people are seeing all around us and
it's quite interesting because there is
sort of an unholy alliance between many
of these islamists and many of the
leaders um in the west in fact
researching that i stumbled across a
document from the head of al qaeda in
libya in 2016 urging the islamists to
make a deal with the eu and nato because
he cites unprecedented levels of support
that they had from the obama
administration at the time and you know
that's very curious we've never really
understood why western leaders and
american leaders are in such a rush to
give the islamists their caliphate the
by demonstration just did it in
afghanistan and you know these are
questions really for the administration
to answer and unfortunately you know we
live in such a tyrannical society these
days known as the united states of
america that we don't get to ask those
questions yeah yeah well it's a lot of
unique reporting and people of course
can see it on fox nation congratulations
to you in another season uh laura logan
thanks for joining us hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now